look who's joining us in studio as
promised right here my colleague from
the NFL Network man spent many many a
moon with the Green Bay Packers non NFL
seasons he is from the San Jose State
University good to see you James Jones
what's your draft weekend memory what's
your favorite trip oh man my draft
weekend memory was I was sitting at the
house seeing all these receivers go in
front of me that I felt like I was
better than and I got up and I said I'm
out of here turn the draft off my wife
was like no just wait a couple more pics
and then seen a 900 area cold pop up on
my phone
coach Mike said is James and I said yep
he said we're gonna take you with this
next pic and I thought it was one of my
buddies messing around so I'm like man
who is this on the phone last I'm
playing this year coach Mike me knowing
him now as long as this James with you
know deep little voice and I'm like oh
man this is real man
next thing I know is 50,000 people in my
little apartment man everybody excited
man it's a special time man so you were
just watching the screen just watching
this growing up seeing all these guys go
man I'm seeing all the Jacoby Jones is
everybody everybody going and I'm like
hey man so I'm like I'm done watching
this but turn it off and you know go
watch my buddy played uh arena football
so I said go watch some arena football
and my wife talked me into watching a
couple more picks and then that's when I
went okay did you have a meeting with
Green Bay did you have a workout with
never talked to Green Bay one out of
here never talked to Green Bay one time
at the combine had no clue I thought I
was gonna go to the Falcons the Falcons
was the one team that was met with him
as a whole coaching staff receiver coach
owned there's everybody so I came home
from the draft I'm telling my family
like listen man hey keep your eyes open
whenever the Falcons is on the clock as
we going to the Falcons I never spoke to
the Green Bay Packers one time so when
you got the call from Mike McCarthy was
he getting his back worked on no I think
he was extremely focused at that time
right the only thing is that we'll get
to that in a moment let's talk about the
let's talk about the latest rumor
or let's put it this way reports that
after all of this and by this I mean
from combbind to this very Monday of
draft week that Cuyler Murray was
absolutely going to be the first overall
pick in the draft because of so many of
the connective tissues between the coach
and Cuyler Murray and the offense being
brought in what do you make of the
report that the Cardinals you know in
your the state in which you live right
now are gonna go in a different
direction when they're on the clock
Thursday night I think it's the
Cardinals trying to basically trick
everybody how I think art Cuyler Murray
is their guy I think they're coming out
saying this stuff right now because
they're trying to get some trade value
for rosin and you come out you say he's
such a great leader he's such a great
player he's impressing the socks off the
coach and practice you come out and you
say all these things all man we're not
thinking about taking a quarterback now
because what we've seen from rosin you
say all these things because you want to
get some good trade value for him and
the markets probably not that good right
now so you keep pumping them up and
plumping them up and hopefully a team
takes a chance on him but I still think
this is a no-brainer I still think you
got the coach you wanted he's gonna put
in the office that fits around Cuyler
Murray your offensive line is not great
this kid is mobile this is the right
pick I think this is a no-brainer for
the car James Jones the NFL Network
analyst here on the Rich Eisen show what
are the odds though that rosin did come
in in the offseason workout program week
and did in fact get on the field and
throw it around a little bit and the
coaches saw and Kings Murray got his
first personal look-see at this
quarterback and said hey maybe this is
where we should go because we have so
many other holes I mean it's very good
odds I mean we're talking about a top 10
pick last year I mean we've seen this
kid standing in the pocket at UCLA
making great throws I mean whether his
back shoulder throws whether it's seven
steps drops and the ball is out on big
Tom Post I mean we know he has a
big-time arm we know when he's protected
and he's standing in the pocket I mean
he can make every throw I mean we seen
some of that last year when he was
protected he made some great throw so
I'm
with the eyeball test as a new coach
coming in I mean you're looking at a
first-round quarterback so when you're
at practice in the pockets clean I'm
sure they're like that and this kid
can't sling the ball he can he can throw
it you know maybe we can't build I'm
sure some of that you know has come in
there but when you look at a kid like
Kyler Murray and you look at the type of
team the Cardinals have and the holes
that they have not only on the offense
but the defense is well I mean you got
to get an explosive playmaker in there
and a guy I could touch the ball every
play at the quarterback spot you can't
pass him yeah I mean it's just been a
fascinating couple of weeks for sure in
in Arizona where Murray showed up the
week that the offseason workout program
window opens up and so Murray is being
interviewed or having his tires kicked
just as Rosen's in the building how
weird do you think that was in that
locker room it's weird for Rosen but I
think they did that so some of the
veteran guys could come up and meet
Colin Murray and maybe talk to him and
you know he could get to know some of
his teammates because that's the route
that they were thinking about going
because that's the only reason why you
bring a guy in there when you're right
but when you're about to start offseason
programs so he can meet some of these
veterans he can meet the guys you know
me talk to him because they know that's
the route they gonna go in the dress
okay so what James Jones here again nine
seasons in the National Football League
against including most of them with the
Green Bay Packers right here in the Rich
Eisen show what do you think of the
receiving corps that's available this
year all right I mean obviously we've
seen the comma we've seen a lot of the
guys I mean test out of the water but
all my years in Green Bay and all my
years playing and even now when you look
across the National Football League a
lot of the big time wide receivers are
late round picks and when I say late I
mean second third or fourth it smoking
like a tree think of Antonio Browns of
Jarvis Landry's the t y Hill the Davante
Adams I mean these guys the Keene and
Allen's I mean these guys are late picks
Edelman - yeah they go all the way the
last room to keep going I mean there's
some a lot of the top receivers in the
league or late round pick so I'm not
really a fan on man get this guy in the
first round and he can you know change
those these it's very few
Julio Jones and Calvin Johnson's out
there you know what I'm saying so I look
at guys going in the second third round
I love Keyshawn Johnson out of Fresno
State
I love Stanley Morgan jr. out of
Nebraska I think these are two guys that
could come in right now that you could
get in a second at they're around gonna
be immediate impact players immediately
starters on your football team and if
these guys come out last year especially
Stanley Morgan Jr he's possibly a
first-round pick so I look at guys like
that I'm excited about to see where they
go cuz I think they can land in some
good spots and and they can be the top
guys in this league so what is the
prototypical receiver do you think that
needs to be if you could build one for
the 2019 NFL season what would that be
you know like who who what do you need
or is it you're still the same
attributes to succeed at the position I
think in the National Football League
one thing receivers need to know how to
do is run routes like you're gonna find
those guys who can run forward three
you're gonna find these dudes who are
big and strong but if you cannot run
routes and separate and get in and out
of your break you're not gonna be
successful and that's what happens a lot
of these guys that are in college and
they come out in a test will and you're
coming from Alabama where you come from
these big time schools where your
quarterback is well protected and you
got nine seconds to run around you've
got all day to get open you look good
but then when you get in the National
Football League and you have three four
seconds to get open you better separate
like that you know and you haven't had a
coach teaching you how to run routes and
how to get open you struggle and I think
that's why we see a lot of big time why
receives from big time school struggle
because when you get to the National
Football League it's happening a lot
faster you don't have all day
to get open you have to get in and out
of your break and when you get a lot of
guys in the later rounds and all that
they've been trained for that they've
been getting in and out of their breaks
they might not have a very good
quarterback you know to deliver the ball
so they had to get creative with their
routes and get open and I think that's
what you need in the National Football
it's certainly now I mean you want to
talk about getting used to something in
the NFL now the eye in the sky is gonna
be looking at offensive pass
interference
and how many of these young kids are
gonna get popped for that this year I
think I think we're in trouble with that
penalty right there on both sides of the
ball I mean it's it's gonna be some
calls that go to replay and we're all
gonna be sitting here like we got to
change this rule you think so I think so
because I mean there's holding and
fighting on every play you know it's
gonna be some push offs it's gonna be
some little tug and here and there I
mean that's football so now you get to
challenge that and come in and challenge
these pass interference and things like
I think the NFL has made a big mistake
and I do not like the rule I mean just
let the guys go out there you missed a
call we call it changed the whole game
you missed it
it happens they've missed plenty of
calls but now you can replay these I
think we're looking at longer games I
think we're looking at penalties that
people are gonna be like why we even
looking at we might be we might be
looking at we might be looking at longer
last two minutes because the same number
of challenges the pool of challenges
from which coaches can reach for the
flag is the same so it's not it's so
coaches are gonna have to think do I
really challenge that dpi here with
three minutes to go in the first quarter
at war when are they gonna have that
thing or or they'll do it early and
won't have it late it's the last two
minutes
what will 3:45 Park Avenue buzz in what
will somebody buzz in with I just think
it's such a touchy touchy penalty
because as a receiver when you push off
why are you pushing off because he's
holding me so as a coach you're saying
man that's offensive pass interference
so you go challenge it and then before
he pushes off you see the kid holding
him you know what I mean so I mean as a
referee how are you gonna say oh that's
on the defense or the offense like he
did push off but he was holding him
before the ball came like how are you
gonna do I think we're gonna get a lot
of controversial calls and challenges
and I don't I don't think it's gonna be
good okay speaking of touchy subjects
let's get to it the bleacher report
article on your former team yeah
although for you I'm sure once a packer
always a packard you were very vocal
immediately I know you you you facetimed
in on NF
total axis the day that the piece came
out saying well I don't wanna say
defending because that means that you
wouldn't defend others in this scenario
what did you make of the piece that had
Aaron Rodgers in the coach at such
loggerheads in so many accusations
flying back and forth about who was to
blame for the situation their reason why
the reason why I came on so fast is
because I I just I thought it was
ridiculous and like I was like I said on
the show the guy I know Aaron Rodgers
and I was getting texts from everybody
like where was I at when all this was
going on when all these players coming
out saying this about Aaron and this
about like where was I at because I
didn't see that like Aaron wasn't that
type of teammate to me and when I listen
to these players talk the first thing I
think about is the locker room cold if I
got a problem with rich I'm not gonna go
on total access and say man I got a
problem with rich I'm gonna talk to rich
in the back and tell rich I'm gonna call
rich i'ma tell rich man look this is the
problem we have so I felt like number
one you're Michael Gregg ginnis if
you've got a problem with Aaron Rodgers
man call him don't put it all in the
media saying this stuff that stuff
because you know eight nine times out of
ten Aaron Rodgers not gonna come out in
the media and defend yourself you know
he's just gonna let it brush over like
whatever I'm not really paying attention
to that and for those guys to come out
and say the things they said about Aaron
I mean it hurt because when they were in
the locker room it wasn't like that
like Greg Jimmy's and Aaron Rodgers had
a very good relationship in the locker
room same as your michael finley and
Aaron Rodgers you know and then you
leave and you say these things about
Aaron Rodgers and the organization and
all that and then I mean like I to me
Greg is my guy mmm like I'm the
Godfather to his daughter he is my man
but right now he knows I will tell him
this I think he's he was he was
sensitive he was sensitive because you
know maybe Aaron Rodgers didn't come out
and say man we want to keep Greg
Jennings and all that when he was in his
forty was coming for free eight I don't
I don't know why exactly he's
since there may be when we were on the
field and Erin Ryder said oh man you
come giddy if you really know Aaron
Rodgers Aaron Rodgers is a comedian in
the locker room 24/7 all he does is joke
so if you know Aaron and you and Aaron
are out here killing every team we play
like you your stats are out of the water
you think he really wants to let you go
I think Greg was I think he was really
sensitive and I think it it hurt him the
comments that he said but still man you
don't you don't turn around and say that
a bunch of well so again you're
referring to the Carlos Rogers in
Scenario in the piece where he's playing
for the Niners and with Jennings balling
out he says why don't you come get him
next year because it's Jennings was
having an issue getting a long-term
contract at the time and if Gino anyhow
all jokes well he does kind of know her
know so that's that's the that's a head
scratch your michael finley idea was
sort of a a foregone conclusion that he
does not like Aaron Rodgers and he will
under well I don't I mean all the things
12 has done for him I don't even see how
you could come out and even talk bad
about a guy like that I mean this is a
guy that you know team meeting over
everybody going to sleep I'm coming into
your room making sure you know these
plays making sure you know the
assignments you know you get hurt I'm
the first one at the hospital you know
him and him and him and you're Michael
Finley in practice he always helping J
Mike always was there for J Mike so I
don't know where these comments are
coming from J Mike's and Aaron's such a
bad teammate and things like that
because from what I seen
I mean J might should have been like me
the one coming out having Aaron's back
all the stuff he's done for them well
and it's Jennings I didn't realize the
the how deep the animus was for him
towards Rogers he said that he has
called Aaron he's tried to yeah and what
has he told you if whatever you can
share be honest once you when I talked
to Greg I don't even talk to Greg about
this about the situation I've never sat
down and been like Greg man why you and
Aaron you know I haven't even talked to
him about the situation but me knowing
Greg but I mean knowing Greg H extremely
well I just feel like and like if he was
sitting right here right now I will tell
him s stop being sense
that won't like well what about the idea
because he did when he was on the show
he even said to me when he was sitting
in that air that that Rodgers would
change plays because he did not agree
with what was coming out of Mike
McCarthy's head said is that is that
does that ring true to him this last
season oh this is this this is it
so coach Mike came in near his second
year and said the ball at each team mean
the ball is in the quarterbacks hands he
can get and change into any play he
wants to get into and we all set in that
meeting like thank God Aaron could get
to any play change any play like this is
this is gonna be good and that's when we
really took off with the no huddle
offense now at some plays that will come
in and we'll be strong right 324
Denver's one of our favorite third down
plays eronel here to San Francisco 49ers
over there a watched ever watch the
slants that's the play we're not gonna
run great you know so as a smart
quarterback and as coach Mike putting
the ball in his hands all right let's
get out of this place so why does it
come out that with the spin that Rodgers
is being mutinous and and McCarthy is
being clueless why does it why is that
spin out there the best you can tell me
James to be honest with you I think when
you get like a lot of the new guys that
come in and they may see it for the
first time of Aaron change of play and
they hear through through his head said
that this is the play and hearing
changes a play made they may be coming
from Jacksonville they may be coming
from places where this is not allowed so
now you're looking at it and you're like
oh my goodness he's changing the play
well he has the ability to change the
place and every time him and Mike came
in and had a team meeting and if we were
watching film of him changing plays and
all that it was nothing said it was
nothing said now end means with him and
Mike alone I don't know but it was
nothing said it was maybe you could have
got to this or maybe you should've did
that or maybe you could have left it on
and it might have worked but it would
never was like an argument of stop call
changing the place and it never was none
of that last two questions for you on
this James Jones before I send you up
the 405 to the NFL Network to be on NFL
total access
so the McCarthy portions of the story
did any of that ring true that he would
leave meetings towards the end best you
could hear to get all back while I was
not there but this is all I'm gonna say
when I was in Green Bay I had a I had a
steady schedule so I would go to I will
go to work practice be over at five
o'clock I'll go see the family come back
kids go to sleep I come back like eight
sitting asana sitting the jacuzzi try to
give my body to recover when I pulled up
coach Mike's still there when I'm
leaving 10 o'clock at night coach Mike's
still there coach Mike was one of these
coaches that is in the building at 6:00
in the morning out at 12:00 every day so
when people come out and they say all
coach Mike is good it's hard for me to
believe because I know what it meant for
coach Mike to win he used to always
coming to team meeting and say nobody
cares about no stats nobody cares about
nothing the only thing we care about is
winning so it's hard for me to believe
that coach Mike is sneaking somebody and
getting massages and that's what
everybody's talking about now in Green
Bay or you know but the coach coach I
know coach Mike night and day 24/7 in
the building trying to get better and
that's the coach Mike I know so it's
hard for me to believe that he's he's in
while we're practicing our in meetings
he's up there give him aside and last
one what about the hearing now what are
you hearing about Rogers with his new
coach Matt Lafleur I said I've said on
this show that Rogers is way too smart
to realize to not realize that this is
the last five six years of his window of
his the championship viability here and
that if this guy has any remote clue
he's gonna try and work with him and if
not maybe he'll try and figure something
out of his own right but no doubt to
sabotage it I don't think makes any
sense
right now don't know be difficult
understands right now and you know he
just signed a big deal but he knows we
got a small window you know it's not I
got 10 years left you know as I got
probably three four or five years at a
high level playing this game so we got a
win now and when I said I'm gonna talk
to him and Devante I mean there
sited about it he sat down with the new
coach at dinner with him and all that
and excited about what he got going on
and you know the things he's gonna be
able to do on the office so he knows
this it's time to go it's a short window
and we got to get it done now so I don't
think you're gonna see no problems are
you know have these articles come out of
him and the coach hair button and all
that now they both competitors they're
gonna want to win I mean we all
understand that but I think he's decided
he ready to go cuz he knows the windows
small we gotta go any idea what the
conference gonna look like is it gonna
be different I think you know I think a
lot of it'll be the same with a couple
little tweaks here and there but I think
he'll keep a lot of the stuff Aaron
Rodgers was doing that he really loved
under coach Mike maybe named a little
different things like that but I think a
lot of it'll be similar with a with a
little tweaks of the way he likes to
call game good to see you at 89 Jones n
TAF that's James Jones on Twitter check
him out on NFL Network tonight and also
all week long we are gonna be from
Nashville you're gonna be part of our
draft conversation good to see you sir
you got it that's James Jones here on
the Rich Eisen show Dwayne Haskins still
to come and check in around the rest of
the sports weekend here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app